Andrew tapate did this thing about how
can you be a man from Canada imagine
being from Canada imagine saying I'm a
man from where from Canada well that
doesn't go together what are you talking
about wait you're a man from Canada
can't be and Drake is in the comments
green light I don't think it's happening
but what about the people that do that
kind of behavior for him I don't think
he is going to publicly say green light
and then it's a green light of course
you know what I mean no but all of his
super fans or people who want to get in
good with him I can see them easily
being like oh [__] he put that message
out there he just needs one bar I mean
he got the czechoslovakians and the
yugoslavians ready to V he gave him one
bar and I see him posting like crazy
Yugoslavia don't even exist no more
every country that used to be part of
Yugoslavia is charged the [__] up you
know those boys don't play around I
think that's who he hires to take out T
he's back to being a feminist hero women
are going to love him yeah for all the
dogs for all the [__] bro